Саме біля цього будинку в Охтирці Сумської області велися перші бої, коли колони росіян прямували до міста.
Там застряг навіть снаряд від "Град", прямо біля першого балкона, біля лавки стирчав, застряг, не розірвався.
Ми якраз були в підвалі, всі ховалися… І от такий якраз почули струс. Вийшли – стирчить цей снаряд.
Якби він розірвався, то пів будинку точно не було б цього.
А на сусідні будинки, за розповідями місцевих, ворожі війська скидали вакуумні бомби.
4-го в нас вакуумну бомбу скинули, дім розбили навпроти і хвилею розбили в нас пів даху з тієї сторони, всі вікна.
Це нам вставили зараз вікна.
Через вибухові хвилі у людей не залишилося жодного вцілілого вікна чи балкону,
системи опалення були перебиті осколками, а труби – замерзли і потріскалися.
Частину ремонтних робіт людям оплатили міжнародні організації, а місцева влада дала матеріали на ремонт даху.
За решту – людям довелося платити з власної кишені.
Скидаємося, тому що треба. За дах дали нам безплатно профіль. Ну а за роботу нам довелося скидатися, платити.
І так залишилося це ж у нас у під'їздах вікна, це ми плівкою пооббивали.
Двері навісили старі, але вони не закриваються вхідні.
Балконний блок за свої гроші засклили, замовили скло.
Засклили, тому що нам жити треба якось було. У нас немає де жити, не було.
Щоб привести будинок до ладу, ОСББ вирішило податися на програму "Віднови дім" від Фонду енергоефективності.
Вона фінансується за кошти Європейського Союзу і на 100% покриває ремонтні роботи
з відновлення будинків, які постраждали від російського вторгнення.
Загалом на цю програму виділено фінансування з боку європейських партнерів 25 млн євро,
з них 5 млн євро – це перший пілотний етап.
У першому пілотному етапі беруть участь ОСББ,  ті будинки, в яких створено об'єднання співвласників
багатоквартирних будинків, які розташовані на території шести областей та міста Києва.
Це Київська область, це Житомирська область, Сумська, Чернігівська
і зараз нещодавно додалися ще дві області – це Миколаївська та Дніпропетровська області.
Та є певні обмеження щодо участі у програмі.
Не повинно бути значних пошкоджень, тобто руйнування опорних конструкцій будівлі.
Їх спочатку потрібно відновити, потім вже брати участь в програмі і відновлювати ті конструкції, які пошкоджені.
Це вікна, балкони, фасади, покриття, дахи та також загальнобудинкові котли або інженерні мережі.
Саме ці роботи підлягають 100% відновленню і фінансуванню.
Щоб подати заявку на отримання гранту – потрібно провести загальні збори ОСББ,
проголосувати, а потім замовити звіт з обстеження будівлі.
Гранти дають саме ОСББ, бо легше працювати з однією юридичною особою
і контролювати кошти, щоб не було зловживань.
Тому і підрядника, який проводитиме ремонтні роботи, також обирає ОСББ.
Після цього подається заявка з супровідними документами, складається договірна ціна між ОСББ і підрядниками
і подається заявка із супровідними документами.
Заявка може подаватися як онлайн, так і в паперовому вигляді.
Після того, як вона пройде процес схвалення фондів і наших партнерів МФК,
які також адмініструють цю програму з боку Європейського Союзу,
заявка схвалюється і виплачується аванс в сумі 70% від вартості проєкту.
Програма почала діяти з кінця листопада минулого року.
У чотирьох будинках вже повністю завершили ремонтні роботи, ще 15 – зараз на стадії відновлення.
17 травня після  бомбардування у нас був пошкоджений будинок.
Пошкодження були першої категорії. Не було вікон, заклинені двері,
зруйнований дах, сараї, гаражі зруйновані.
Ми проконсультувалися,  зібрали збори ОСББ, загальні збори і вирішили  звернутися до фонду.
Проголосували, зробили протокол, написали заявку,   попросили, щоб розглянули нашу заявку.
Ми взяли участь у цій програмі.
Завдяки фонду нині у нас стоять вікна, у нас стоять балкони і у нас будинок  придатний до життя.
Після того як ОСББ отримує аванс, ці кошти переказують підрядній організації.
Цього авансу вистачає, щоб повністю виконати всі роботи.
Далі ОСББ подає заявку про завершення робіт.
Вона проходить ту ж процедуру схвалення і тоді фонд перераховує решту суми.
Максимальна сума, яку можуть перерахувати одному ОСББ – 7,2 млн гривень.
Це спосіб IFC (Міжнародної фінансової корпорації) разом з ЄС підтримати українські сім’ї на тлі російського вторгнення в Україну,
щоб підвищити стійкість житлового сектора країни, а також полегшити фінансовий тягар уряду в житловому секторі.
Програма розрахована до квітня 2026 року,
але ми маємо намір завершити всі ремонтні роботи значно раніше.
Програма знаходиться на пілотній стадії. На це виділили 5 мільйонів євро.
І це включає відновлення приблизно 70-80 будинків, що залежатиме від розміру будинків і пошкоджень, яких вони зазнали.
Основною вимогою програми є ще й енергоефективність.
Тому усі вікна, двері та балконні рами, які встановлюють, мають трикамерні склопакети і задуті аргоновим газом.
Ми будемо відпрацьовувати і вимоги у нас по обладнанню матеріалом у фонді, щоб всі вікна, балконні рами були енергоефективні.
Щоб це не просто закрили, як-то кажуть, від вітру і дощу, щоб не дуло, а для того, щоб стояли енергоефективні вікна,
щоб будинок менше споживав тепла.
Відповідно, якщо в квартирі будуть стояти енергоефективні вікна - це, відповідно, зразу на 3-4 градуси квартира буде тепліша.
3-4 градуси - це фактично на 15-20% зменшення споживання газу для опалення цього будинку.
Це і економія, це і екологічні питання, відповідно, менше на 20% буде викидів СО2.
Такі енергоефективні вікна вже стоять у цьому будинку в Сумах.
Він  знаходиться на околицях міста і першим потрапив під бомбардування ворожих літаків, які летіли з Курської області.
Одна з бомб впала в полі біля будинку. Вікна вибило і в даховій котельні, що загрожувало всьому будинку.
Це обладнання дуже важливе, і воно належить до категорії небезпечних в обслуговуванні.
І тут повинна підтримуватися певна і температура, і захист повинен підтримуватися.
І що у нас відбулося? Коли цей будинок постраждав від бомбардування,
то вікно, яке виходить на сторону з кордоном з Росією, його повністю було вибито.
Навпроти вікно постраждало від вибухової хвилі.
Фактично тут працюють газові горілки, які тими протягами, які тут були, через вибиті вікна могли задути.
Відповідно, стало питання в першу чергу відновити саме це приміщення, де знаходиться небезпечне обладнання,
для того, щоб була можливість експлуатувати його в опалювальний сезон.
На цей момент Фонд отримав 62 заявки на участь у програмі на загальну суму 130 мільйонів гривень.
Вони розглядаються 10 днів, а ремонтні роботи тривають максимум півтора місяця.
Загалом за гроші, які виділив Європейський Союз, зможуть відновити до пів тисячі пошкоджених будинків.
Тому зараз очікують на нові заявки з областей.